of Cassandras in Flint Michigan hi
Cassandra how are you I'm good how are
you Dave better than I deserve what's up
well we just started wearing baby step
two we started December of last year
2016 and one of the agreements when we
started was my husband was adamant not
to give up that 15% we were putting in
our 401k so we've been plugging along
we've started out with a hundred and
sixteen three hundred and fifty thousand
that's including our mortgage and we've
paid off since then 25580 so we both
been still putting 15% away in as we're
doing this and then of course things
have come up my daughter got homecoming
court I have a daughter in college she's
singing most of her tuition we helped
her out a little bit so things there's
been hiccups but I'm wanting to sell my
car I'm wanting to got my 15% at least
I'm just wondering if that's what I
should do or should we just keep
plugging along like we have been well
I've already told you what my plan is
you don't need to ask me what my plan is
you already know the only question is
are you going to be my plan or your plan
right I want to be your plan he doesn't
I mean he does to a point but no he's a
hundred sixteen thousand dollars in debt
and I'm not apparently my plan doesn't
suck
I agree okay so I mean well it's a dr.
Phil moment that's what you do you look
at him it's dr. Phil moment how's it
working for you it's not the best laid
plans that he laid in place got you
where you are and I'm not picking on him
but that's kind of Erica right
that's like me sitting here fat going on
like your diet plan well and we have
between the two of us with our four oh I
have a 403b he has a 401k and we have
almost 800,000 in there now so my thing
is like it's not going to hurt us to
give that up him yeah thank ya for
really he's worried about that I don't
know are you worried
thousand dollars if there weren't if he
was 72 and had $2.00 I know I can't
convince them but I'm gonna drop mine
and I want to know what you guys need
get on the same page a knucklehead needs
to get his knuckle out of his head thank
you I'm serious I mean the app yeah you
guys have done great you got eight
hundred thousand freaking dollars so if
you want to work your plan the two of
you work your plan but if you're gonna
work my plan I teach people to stop
putting money in retirement and quickly
by intense focus clean up the 401k so
have you guys read the Total Money
Makeover or been the financial piece or
anything we both read the Total Money
Makeover and then flunked a book report
he flunked the book report cuz there's a
whole segment in there that explains the
logic behind stopping this on a
temporary basis and the power of focus
it's a whole section in the book go find
it again read it to him I will I'm gonna
and I've mentioned the FQ classes which
he's willing to do but then what it cost
for that he he doesn't want spend $99
he's got eight hundred thousand dollars
and he's screwing up the plan I can't
this guy's a knucklehead he's a
knucklehead I would give it to you but I
think he ought to pay for it so
otherwise so I'm not gonna give it to
you because I don't think he's gonna
appreciate it until he pays for it Oh
Lord bless your heart sweetie but y'all
just keep working on it you just gotta
decide what you're gonna do but that's
the plan the reason we do this stuff is
because it works better than your plan
it's that simple and and I've explained
all of that and he knows all of that but
he's smart so there you go smart people
are the hardest you know it's dumb
people like me that you know when you
reach a point that you gave up that
surrender moment that's the best moment
of your life when you go I don't know
how to fix this would you show me how
and then you submit yourself to a plan
you know you hire a personal trainer
that come in you're you know they come
in and show you an exercise program when
you go you know I think I'm dropping
gonna do those push-ups a little
different than that I think you know I
know you pay the personal trainer you
submit yourself to the system that they
bring in
because they have abs and you have a keg
I mean that's why you do this you submit
yourself to learning something or
someone that knows more than you and
that smart people don't do that
sometimes which means they're not wise
but they're smart I to it - I'm a
hardhead - I'm gonna go ahead - but you
guys all know what I'm talking about you
don't have to fix my plan it's not
broken there's only one thing I know is
this and I really know this this is the
Dave Ramsey show hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
you
[Applause]
[Music]